what's your verdict on the meaty of the
parcel it wasn't at the meeting but I've
obviously heard reports of it I think we
have made a mistake in giving so much
ground to Osborn particularly on the
question of the treatment of young
people by the budget and particularly on
children in larger families I think it's
it's very unfair on them why should the
third fourth or whatever a subsequent
number of children be penalized because
of the random date in which they were
born well I suppose the counter-argument
is why should the taxpayer pay for
people to have large families who can't
afford them we have a system in which we
support all children even Margaret
Thatcher signed the UN Convention on the
Rights of the Child of child equality
and child values so why should we say
that was because it I was born the force
and foot I'm devil's advocate here I'm
not there's a especially personal
opinion let's be clear about this but
the argument the argument would be that
this is only going to be introduced for
future families that parents have a
choice how many children they have and
at a time when other things are being
cut that encouraging parents to have
smaller families might be a good thing
I think encouraging for parents to have
smaller families is a good thing and how
giving them an incentive
it helps us anyway look at the average
family size over the past 50 years has
come down and come down in most of
Europe but the idea that because there
are some large families those children
should be penalized because of the
because of being born basically not
right so I mean Harriet Harmons argument
is that labor lost the election that we
know from opinion polls people do
believe there is room to cut the welfare
budget and then at some point labour if
it wants to get reelected needs to get
in line with majority can I give you two
ways we can cut them off for budget
control private-sector rents in London
and the southeast you'd save billions on
Housing Benefit because that for housing
benefit capped levels goes largely
towards paying the rent of people
secondly we have in work benefits which
subsidizes low wages even employees of
successful companies like Tesco most
eBay or many ways George Osborne now
because they that's what that's what he
wants to do he's
with me actually you're in agreement or
I but they say you would cut in work
there was excrement I would raise wages
as a way of reducing benefits and ii
wouldnt work taxpayer but the problem is
living wage suggestion is it doesn't
actually make anybody ticular
particularly better off because he's
changed the threshold of benefits surely
what we need is to actually recognize
the minimum wage is too low the living
wage is barely a sustainable wage in
which to live surely if we make sure
people are paid more then they do better
the economy does better a tax income
goes that is the Tory argument but I
mean who pays for all this in the
meantime in the meantime we have to
recognize taxes of course we have to
recognize there are desperate levels of
poverty within our society child poverty
has increased in Britain in the past
five years homelessness as increase and
overcrowding in houses is increased so
we need a different approach to welfare
I just wanna ask you a few other
questions about policy at the moment
suggestion that mechanism to which
Britain does contribute the European
financial support mechanism could be
used to help Greece would you be for or
against that if it meant that British
taxpayer had an exposure there's a
humanitarian crisis in Greece and I
think we should be prepared to help on
that but the question of Greece and its
presence in the euro is really something
that's separate from the UK economy I
mean I don't know how it's all going to
play out it may well still be this would
help them open their banks in the short
term should they have an unsustainable
debt and that means that if the
unsustainable debt cannot be paid and
everyone that's lent the money is going
to take a haircut including British
banks yeah
yes oh yeah well you you would say as
part of being a member of the EU we
should support and we've done the same
with other countries African and Latin
American countries where there's been a
debt restructuring right and yet the
other one is the what David Cameron's
been saying today about concentrating
defense spending on specifically on
drones and on special forces to deal
with is would you support them we
already spend far more than most
European can't
defense were on 2% and Tory's no I don't
I'd rather we had a lower level of
defense expenditure we could start by
not renewing trident although that yeah
the biggest event that isn't the biggest
element of expenditure I think
involvement in the war in Syria is very
problematic and quite dangerous now the
suggestion we bomb is now being put on
the back burner apparently until about
drove until system using drones is the
same thing but it's less risky for the
people that doing the bombing but what
does it do on the ground how many
civilians is it going to kill and what's
the long-term of that surely we need to
look at yeah look at the crisis and know
it is Christ in Syria but we've also got
to look at where's the arms coming from
Saudi Arabia where's the money coming
from where's the oil being so will you
get on that on that specific policy you
wouldn't support using drones
no of course special forces are troops
on the ground would you review some well
that this is where you get mission creep
because once you take the principle that
you're gonna put British troops into
Syria into the war in Syria it's pretty
unfortunate for Special Forces yeah and
they are not successful in the immediate
objective you then follow up and we then
find we're back into an Iraq type
situation I think we've got to look at
the keywords for that either I would
support much more doing doing much more
for Refugees quickly those in Lebanon
but also looking at the role of Saudi
Arabia and Turkey particularly in the
way in which I still survive and finally
in in this contest to become labor
leader where do you think you are now
it's a fascinating process huge turnout
all the hustings lots of good questions
coming up I think we're in a position
where a lot of party members are saying
we got it wrong on the economy in 2015
we were offering austerity like when the
Tories were offering austerity heavy we
should be offering an economic strategy
which is about rebalancing and improving
the economy reducing unemployment and
underemployment you're you're being put
at second or possibly first at the
moment is that where you
I don't follow these things that closely
I just go from hustings to hustling and
meeting to meeting and answer lots of
questions and take part in some
fascinating debates and it's brought the
whole contest to life we've got loads of
people joining the party because they
want to get rid of a Tory government
they want a Labour Party that really
represents anything they're a bit of a
minority there and everyone else is
having a laugh at the Labour Party's
expense well as 50,000 people joined the
Labour Party in the last two months
that's quite a lot 30 million voters
what 30 million votes there's 30 million
voters there are 9 million people that
voted labour in the last election and I
want that number to increase and you
have to start with a much bigger much
more active party and that's what we're
doing ok thank you very much Derek over